my girlfriend is seven years dumped me
two months after she moved to
Connecticut for graduate school she told
me she needed time to think because
something is missing in our relationship
and she needs time to figure out what it
is I'm not a mind reader but if someone
has been with you for seven years and
they need to time to think about whether
they still want to be with you that's
not a good sign yes your instincts are
correct I would say I have been
absolutely devastated and depressed I'm
ashamed to admit this but the other
night I found myself on my bedroom floor
crying in the fetal position well that's
totally normal and it's also it's a
healthy thing to do cry it out of it
don't drink it out of you or jump off a
balcony those are dumb that men do women
get down on the floor cry in the fetal
position I think that's why they live
longer so please continue doing that
it's a valid human emotion that both men
and women have that men fight